so
greta turnburg one of the great heroines
of our time
greta tunberg is basically
like jesus in every single conceivable
way except for none of them but she is a
little child will lead them
and she's no longer a child she's an
adult so i can make fun of her as much
as i want
and uh and greta tunberg appeared
outside of the summit the cop 26 summit
literally her entire job in life is just
to run around yelling at the adults the
adults have disappointed us you're
you've disappointed greta greta's
disappointed in you
except when she's dancing ecstatically
to rick astley greta's very upset with
you i i honestly don't know what greta's
gonna do with her life when she hits
like 50.
and what do you do at that point you
just yell at the 80 year olds or do you
start yelling at the children in which
case you're just an adult
like right now the the charm and wonder
of greta tunberg is that she was a very
young person and now she's only a
moderately young person yelling at the
adults i feel like by the time she's 23
the magic has worn off a little bit here
but greta totenberg did say but it's
true she says inside here they're all
just they're all just speaking words
verbiage that means nothing nothing
and uh and so she uh went off on the
climate conference she's not wrong
inside cup they're just politicians and
people in power pretending to take our
future seriously to pretending to take
the present seriously of the people who
are being affected already today by the
climate crisis
change is not going to come from inside
there that is not leadership this is
leadership
i i like when she declares herself a
leader that's fun change is not going to
come from wordly to saying things it's
from me
in a field with seven of you say that's
where leadership really comes in
uh
it's so that was pretty that was pretty
great i i enjoyed that
the best part is when she starts cursing
at the adults not the adults it's it's
pretty great uh so um here she continues
with around she's again she's not wrong
all the people who are inside there are
pretending to care about climate change
but don't care enough to actually do
anything because they understand the
reality of the world which is that there
are costs and benefits to policies and
that the benefits when it comes to
radically redefining how the world
economy works
radically
underestimate the cost the cost is way
greater in the near term and the midterm
and the long term if you take the sorts
of drastic action that people like greta
would like you for you to take you
actually wrecked the world economy and
you set the world back a couple hundred
years
all to please a a nordic child who's no
longer a child who's now an adult so she
can just vote like everybody else and
then her voice would be equivalent to
everybody else's so uh but but here she
was going off on on the adults as usual
i'm never going to to stop being pleased
that greta is disappointed in all of us
i just think it's it it's great she's
like a prophet of old and she stands
there and talks about how disappoint
like prophets in the old days they used
to say that god is disappointed in you
because you're sinning
now greta says that she is disappointed
in you it's not that god is disappointed
she is disappointed in you and so long
is credit
honestly i need to wear a bracelet that
says
w w
g t d what would greta tumber do or
i
gt
d
i y
is greta tunde disappointed in you
here
again folks i can make fun of her as
much as i damn well please she's an
adult i've been waiting for like a
couple of years to do this because i
know the rules i know the rules but now
now all bets are off here is greta
thunderberg yelling and cursing about uh
about the adults in the room inside
those bastards
we say no more blah blah blah no more
exploitation of people and nature and
the planets no more exploitation no more
blah blah blah
no more whatever they're doing inside
there
oh she cursed no more blah blah blah i
want an oompa loompa daddy i want it now
i want one i want the world i want the
whole world
i
i i want a party with rooms for of
laughter 10 000 tons of ice cream
i want to wear like braids in my hair i
don't want to share them give it to me
now
and i love that the old people was like
and then joe biden like joe biden when
asked about greta thunderbird and all
this nonsense i just i'll never get over
it i'll never get over the old people
who are actually charged with balancing
the competing interests and then
never watch what they say watch what
they do actually act like rational human
beings when it comes to say pumping gas
because people need gas you get in their
cars and go to work and such
i'll never get over the old people
humoring this
so it's like greta thunderberg being
like
you old man
why aren't you doing what i say you you
bastard what no more blah blah blah
i i i understand what you're saying and
also um i would like to uh sniff your
hair
i don't want you to sniff my hair old
man
blah blah blah blah blah blah
and your buttons like no never gonna
give you a check i do love that song
let's dance together for the planet for
the planet
you know what you know what now i'm
after after this whole thing i'm just
rooting for global warming i've got to
be honest with you i'm rooting for
global warming it's got to take all of
us out because something does we have a
civilization with a death wish and uh
and the longer we humor
corrupt old daughtering idiots and small
children who don't know anything about
the world uh the the uh the worst things
are going to get so
now i'm rooting for global warming i'm
on global warming side now so i'm just
gonna go outside i'm just gonna let my
car idle in the driveway for like a
couple of years for no reason
because humanity deserves it
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment